tonight will be hermond who's coming
arguably off one of his worst starts of
the season against the san francisco
giants he's looking to make up for it at
home right fielder fernando tatis jr now
playing in his third game in the
outfield after coming off the il
and a fastball gets him at 97. pretty
nice sequence came right after him tatis
is just such a dominant presence any
time
you retire him anyway you sort of
breathe a sigh of relief good high
fastball right there as matt strom goes
to work he is making his first start
since august of 2019 in cincinnati it is
his sixth appearance of the year a
chance for the rockies to do quick
damage first and third for story
battle won by straw the straw's credit
he just located that one so here comes
charlie first and third one out now
slowly hit the second and
only one and that'll
produce a run charlie hustling down the
line but just not enough pace on that
ball for frazier to get to it any
quicker awkward angle throw to second
knowing he had to save some time man
aboard for carratini one two carratini's
gone vermont has his second strikeout
brendan rogers singled in the first
inning now a scoring opportunity for the
second baseman with two outs
fly ball
down the right field live fernando
will make the catch fernando was very
aware or at least trying to make himself
very aware of that side wall that one
almost got away from him but he made the
catch
tatis with the strikeout
he has a lot of those 103 but
for a guy with his talent you just live
with that one strike pitch is a ground
ball back of third backhanded by mcmahon
long throw in time to get tatis hustling
down the line good play again by ryan
mcmahon
he might not have all the verve and
flash that nolan aronado could give you
night in and night out
but pretty darn close that young man
especially the throwing arm that's
what's impressive
now manny machado is at the plate has a
equally great arm here's the one two
slider got him
and uh machado sees where the ball went
he's not just gonna turn go back to the
dugout so diaz will wait for a moment
and now officially machado is a
strikeout victim third strikeout for
jeremiah
hermod home run this year three driven
in
come through here with two outs
this ball ride to the left
that's helping your own cause a little
bit isn't it two nothing colorado yeah
fourth rbi of the season for him on this
way you do it brendan rodgers who's one
for two
rockies have
marcus at second connor joe who just
walked is at first base
and this ball in the air to shallow left
and it is going to drop it'll score
another run hermot scores joe to third
in the second is brendan rodgers with a
fly ball double make it three nothing
colorado brendan rogers has enough pop
in his swing
that fam has to play deep
a ball hit like that at petco with the
much
more shallow left field
fam would have gotten to that ball he
did get leather on it just couldn't get
enough of the glove
one two swing and a miss came right back
with the slider and took care of kim
strikeout number four
not only
getting outs but doing it efficiently
through five and two thirds airmon's
thrown just 62 pitches well herman
with two outs when he came to bat in the
fourth inning
had diaz at second and he ripped the
ball to left for a base hit to drive
home
how about another elias to drive in diaz
that's going to go to the wall and
herrera
will go to second with a double
wow
and his biggest fan kyle freeland
leading the cheers from the dugout four
nothing colorado
marcus he's only given up one hit
pitching and he's gone two for three
with two rbis
fernando leads it off here in the
seventh inning for two tonight struck
out swinging in the first inning
high fly ball for fernando to deep
center field back goes hillyard it is
gone
home run for tatis junior his 34th of
the year in the padres are on the board
in the seventh inning fernando to the
rescue chronoworth has done the same
thing twice that's ground down to the
first baseman
fly ball hits a right field in d
blackman going back at the wall he can't
catch it it's off the bottom of the wall
ricochet gets by hillyard chronoworth
heading for third and maybe beyond he's
going to try another inside the park
home run he'll get in his second of the
year
oh the crown zones in denver
the roundy comes on the inside the
parker
and it's four to two blackman gives the
old college try now it's off to the
races it's a little league home run
juice boxes and horn wedges for everyone
but more importantly it gives the padres
some life here tommy pham with one out
van drives one to deep left field that
ball is very gone
oh my goodness it's out on to the
concourse
up and over the pavilion and left
a blast from tommy family's 13th of the
year this is a one-run game
the padres have homered three times in
the seventh this shot seems gonna have
to bear down against uh a tough out in
trent grisham 0-2
and this is softly hit story makes the
catch oh my goodness he robs grisham
of a game-tying base hit to retire the
side in the seventh charlie tonight over
three drove home a run with a fielder's
choice ground ball in the first
charlie drives his ball to deep setter
again this one's got a chance he's done
it two nights in a row
dead center two-run home run
and the rockies lead back to three cj
crone now to hit with the bases empty
still nobody out
this ball crushed deep right center
field take a good look you won't see
this one
back to back jacks you talk about taking
momentum
a rockies win and they win the season
series against the padres
this ball to center field off the end of
the bat here comes hampton he's got it
ball game over
and the rockies have won again against
the padres
that's six in a row in denver for
colorado over san diego